I was six my babysister was murdered
And they never caught him?
Justice was done
You wanna play?
Pika the murders were real
Chucky never was
That's right. He was a fantasy
A delusion
Are you feeling better now?
I don't blame you for being afraid. I was very ill
Chucky told me
He's coming for you.
It's important that we all explore it together as a group
I think I have something wild
Whoa. Hi I'm Chucky, you wanna play?
First he'll kill each and every one of you.
The most horrible ways you can imagine
And then he'll kill me too
Come to momie
Ohh god
Are you afraid of the truth?
terrified
You should be too
night-night
Ha ha ha and they call me sick
bit of another stool
He'll kill us up
A good classic never goes out of style
you